ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
premier ministre vous avez mis le feu au
pays en nous endettant sur une mesure
dont personne ne voulait une mesure près
judiciaire pour le quotidien des
territoires sans pour autant avoir une
efficacité reconnue
je veux parler de 80 kilomètres heure
après six mois d'application
rien ne permet toujours d'affirmer que
la limitation à 80 a réduit le nombre de
tués sur les routes
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
pourtant cette mesure devait être d'une
efficacité immédiate
il n'en est rien le groupe de travail du
sénat sous la haute responsabilité de
michel raison
vous avez fait des proposition
équilibrée acceptable et intelligente
ciblé l'intérieur l'instauration du 80
km heure sur les tronçons accidentogènes
et cela au plus près des territoires par
décision du président du département et
du préfet et conserver le 90 km heure
pour le reste du réseau routier
départemental et surtout ne nous taxer
pas des responsables nous souhaitons
bien sûr que le nombre de morts sur les
routes diminue
nous soutenons toutes les mesures qui
vont dans le sens de l'amélioration de
la sécurité routière de l'état de nos
routes et nos véhicules et du
comportement des automobilistes
après vos ancien ministre de la cohésion
des territoires et de l'intérieur le
président de la république lors de son
tour de france propose de revenir sur
cette mesure et je cite trouver une
manière plus intelligente des solutions
plus pragmatique et faire quelque chose
qui soit plus acceptable alors monsieur
le premier ministre
envisagez-vous de reconsidérer votre
décision et trouver une solution
acceptable par tous envisagez vous de
suivre les propositions intelligentes du
sénat pour vous répondre la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur laurent monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le monsieur le
sénateur vous avez le souligne
effectivement que la question de la
limitation à 80 km/heure sur le réseau
secondaire serait donc au coeur du début
du grand débat qui
est en cours c'est une question
importante vous le soulignez pour nos
concitoyens tant elle touche déplacement
aux mobilités pour ceux notamment qui
vivent en zone rurale et qui parcourt
les quatre cent mille kilomètres de
notre réseau secondaire ce débat donc il
va s'ouvrir avec cette thématique
importante certes de la mobilité mais
aussi de la lutte contre l'insécurité
routière qui reste une préoccupation
forte est un axe fort de la politique de
ce gouvernement dans ce débat il faudra
avoir trois choses en tête la première
et vous nous interroger sur l'efficacité
de la mesure et convient bien évidemment
d'être prudent mais selon les premiers
chiffres provisoires dont nous disposons
sur ce réseau secondaire entre le 1er
juillet 2018 et le 31 décembre 2018 le
nombre de morts a baissé de 13% par
rapport à l'année 2017
deuxièmement il nous appartient il nous
appartiendra également de bien prendre
en compte les effets induits de cette
mesure
je pense notamment au temps de
déplacement je pense notamment aux
effets sur la consommation de carburant
ou encore sur la cohabitation entre les
voitures particulières et les poils au
et nous avons demandé d'ailleurs pour
nourrir ce débat à la délégation
ministérielle à la sécurité routière
routière une étude sur ce point qui sera
bien sûr rendu public et puis il
conviendra également troisième point de
prendre en compte la question de la
responsabilité également des
gestionnaires de voirie qu'à remonter la
vitesse sur un axe si telle devait être
la décision prise en tout ou partie
c'est accepter aussi d'ivoire le cas
échéant l'accent l'accident tabilité
augmenter à nouveau et à cet égard bien
évidemment et je crois que c'est ce que
vous souhaitez la vie des présidents de
conseil départemental sera précieux nous
veillerons avec christophe castaner à ce
que ces analyses soient bien rendu plus
blond klur pour que chacun puisse
exprimer en conscience sur ce sujet
notamment s'il devait être apporté des
aménagements c'est qu'on mesure mais je
sais que nous partageons tous le même
objectif
cet objectif c'est de sauver des vies
humaines merci monsieur boyer je
regrette monsieur le premier ministre
n'ayez pas répondu à ma question car
c'est une mesure que vous avez imposées
nous ne vous demandons pas de reculer et
de vous renier nous vous demandons
vous adapter à la réalité nos
territoires et de donner un signe
d'apaisement et à la colère monsieur le
premier ministre
écouter le sénat écoutez la wada
ruralité et des territoires
si vous aviez écouté le sénat sur
d'autres sujets tels que l'eau
l'assainissement l'augmentation des
taxes la retraite harry caul la csg nous
n'en serions pas là faut conclure nous
sénateurs
nous en appelons à la raison